now there's the metaverse that's coming
along
well have you seen that these companies
are buying like space in like the
metaverse they're buying like plots of
land in the metabolism yeah yeah i've
seen that yeah so they're why they're
buying digital land yeah
dude that's like i mean i feel like it
is just that's some sci-fi territory i i
feel like the past year uh has opened up
basically the age of like the digital
gold rush is this what it must have felt
like to see like the dot-com bubble i
think i think i think so that's that's
that's must have been what it felt like
where you see millions of [ __ ]
dollars being invested in the damage
[ __ ] yeah yeah in like [ __ ]
kittens.com or something like i don't
[ __ ] know and now kittens.com
you're in the metaverse right they don't
have legs have you seen that no they
don't have uh they only have two like
torsos
this is very much similar with me with
nfts i know nothing about the metaphors
so do you know why i saw an art online
by facebook yeah yeah that's all i know
do you want to take a guess why they
only have torsos in this world why
is it for people who perhaps are in
wheelchairs and stuff like that or it's
a very noble thought yeah unfortunately
maybe inclusivity
can you can you actually but to my
understanding it was to stop people like
doing like implying sexual acts and
stuff and doing things
from what i understand from what i
understand that is the reason why i mean
it is like i read somewhere that like
foot fetishes are like i think the most
common fetish in like like the world
what's going to do with facebook
because of the legs
delicious why didn't they just delete
the feet then if they
just have no one from
everyone just looks like kirby you know
just
stubs and knobs apparently it's a
technical issue like the cameras can't
capture the whole body um [ __ ]
i don't think is there anything
mentioned about sexual stuff
can you google sexual mark zuckerberg
metaverse no legs sex
finish finish mark zuckerberg
foot fetish also you can oh sorry turn
off stage yeah
so apparently uh as well there's like a
you have like you're in bubble people
can't come into your space
but to me it's weird right because i
don't know if i'm just like stupid but
it just looks like
really [ __ ] vr chat that's what i saw
and i was like so is this like a game
that facebook is developing or just
looks like vr chat but just less fun and
uh like vr has really good games in it
have you seen this no there's like games
in vrchat and it's nuts i was playing
super monkey ball the other day oh wow
in vrc vr chat how were you not sick i
don't know i'm going to say and there
was also like i could sing playing
regular
like uh
like a tron game where you throw discs
and they bounce around you got to dodge
it that's pretty cool i hit the other
person it just seems like a vr game in a
vr game yeah so it is and there's like
there's a whole cooking game right in a
vr game and it's like free it's like why
the [ __ ] would anyone want how does vr
chat work i never because i've never
played vr chat but is it is it like kind
of like an open source kind of thing
where people can create yeah yeah their
own their own games and their own spaces
and stuff like that okay it's all user
generated okay that's why it's so
[ __ ] good it's like yeah yeah because
you'll be in a lobby and yeah does it is
it annoying that you get in the lobby
and there's like 10 year olds screaming
yeah that's annoying and i think mark
zuckerberg is trying to address that by
making it like age uh only like
over a certain age allowed to join right
yeah
but vr is still really good like it's
it's genuinely good so okay so so going
back to the whole like buying digital
plots of land on on meta okay right like
how does that work
like what i don't know it's all the
question of why well if you own a
digital land it's like the metaverse is
being marketed as this place that is
kind of like just a new virtual reality
world that everyone's going to go to
right so you can literally live like a
second life or even like you know your
online media life in this virtual place
that's called the metaverse so what are
companies doing they're literally buying
plots of land in this virtual land for
treating it like they're they're buying
real lands that exists in the real world
this is just lane this is legitimately
it's like
you want to hit like the most depressing
thing ever please investors are playing
paying millions for virtual land in the
metaverse
and um apparently uh
uh a company recently dropped 2.5
million dollars on a patch of land in
decentral land one of the most popular
metaverse worlds and the prices have
gone up 400 to 500 in the past few
months how much land are we talking like
how many digital how many digital square
meters are we talking i don't fully
understand it
another person uh spent 4.3 million on a
parcel of virtual land
oh my god um
oh my god
is this what happens when you just have
too much money yes i think this is what
i think what's happening is that a lot
of companies with a lot of money are
like let's just throw something into it
all right if it fails it doesn't matter
if it if it goes up tenfold big money
right yeah i think that's what's going
on and i think people in companies are
hearing whispers of it and i think i i
also imagine as well that facebook is
doing a really good job at convincing
these companies oh yeah that this is
going to be a big deal yeah when i feel
like anyone who is in the tech space
looks at metaverse and is like i just
don't see how this can become a thing
that's like good yeah
because how the [ __ ] are you gonna
convince everyone
to get a virtual headset do you know how
annoying they are to i'm i love my tech
and i gotta admit virtual reality
headsets are a pain in the [ __ ] ass
yeah absolutely well it comes with the
uh assumption that
virtual reality headsets will be at one
point more streamlined than they already
are
um which they really really need to be
because like the barrier of entry for
our virtual headset is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] done great obviously yeah that
is facebook yeah and that that is
probably the most user-friendly headset
yeah but it's still like it's not
perfect it's not perfect
you don't want to have a business [ __ ] i
do not want to have a business meeting
without a [ __ ] headset on it's like
honey where's my headset i need to get
into a business one of the main pictures
of like the metaverse like you could
have a a meeting with your co-workers
have you had a virtual reality headset
on for more than two hours no it is i
have it's awful it's it you get sweaty
it's it's like it's bulky the only
reason why i haven't done a stream on my
oculus is because i can't wear that
thing for more than 20 minutes without
feeling sick